let China have its own rule of law what
you read about reminds most of people of
a training camp over training so it
reminds me it's not arbitration camps it
is now law and order very much at stake
in Hong Kong China's recent celebrations
for its 70th anniversary weren't quite
the public relations triumph they were
supposed to be not with continuing
protests in Hong Kong and fresh
revelations about human rights abuses in
the shinjang region my guest this week
here in London is Victor Gao the Chinese
academic and lawyer and vice-president
of the center for China and
globalization
how does he justify China's catalogue of
human rights abuses and the continuing
pressure on Hong Kong
[Music]
let's go welcome to Collinson thank you
for having me
China's always insisted that it will do
anything to avoid chaos it shot a large
number of its own people in Beijing 30
years ago to do that but it's failed
comprehensively to address the protests
in Hong Kong why maintaining stability
has always been a pillar for China's
development since the late 1970s the
Hong Kong's are different ever since
1997 but oldest part of China China has
practiced a one country two systems so
in Hong Kong the primary responsibility
of maintaining law and order is resting
on the shoulders of the Hong Kong SAR
government and the chief executive
carried on the Hong Kong government
that's approved by Beijing absolutely
Hong Kong is part of China and another
one so in Beijing's business not doing
doing it very well is it it's failed its
failed to keep the hated extradition law
didn't it was forced to withdraw that it
tried threats calling the demonstrators
rampant and deranged and warning that a
blow from the sword of law was waiting
for them in the future these threats had
no effect well I think there are China
not understand what it's dealing with I
think there are many different ways to
look at what's happening in Hong Kong I
would say the primary situation right
now is law enforcement you are talking
about restoration of law and order in
Hong Kong and democracy of course when
the British left Hong Kong in 1997 it
did not leave behind a lot of democracy
to talk about but the British did leave
behind deeply entrenched the rule of law
tradition and I think we all need to be
very grateful for that and it is now law
and order very much at stake in Hong
Kong we should not be confused with any
other grievances and political pursuits
in Hong Kong they are important and they
need to be dealt with but law and order
is the primary responsibility of a Hong
Kong
coverman right now perfect okay look at
the results of the local elections in
November
enormous blow to China's prestige 22
years after the territory was handed
over by Britain the pro-democracy camp
tripled its vote from 2015 they won 17
out of 18 councils none of which they
had previously won allow me to make
several points are first of all the
district election result speaks for
itself however the district councils in
Hong Kong cannot operate without
stability and if violence prevailed
none of the 18 District Council's can
really serve the primary purpose they
are set up for you're missing the point
of my question perhaps intentionally I
don't know but the point is that this
was the largest pro-beijing party which
was forced to declare defeat for this
major defeat we said we do not want to
find any excuses and reasons this was
star elite chair of the largest
pro-beijing party this is a big blow to
China's prestige isn't it now my reading
is very different honk wiser democracy
and there is universal suffrage in Hong
Kong for the people in Hong Kong for the
district council elections but therefore
the fact that the election results are
such speak loudly for the fact that Hong
Kong has democratic rights people can
vote whatever they want to do but there
without speak for themselves because
none of the persons running for the
district district council had any
courage to stand out for violence they
stood for legal and lawful means of
exercising their democratic rights I
think that counts so so long as democra
democratic rights are exercised the
peacefully and lawfully everyone is a
winner
no one is a loser what we need to oppose
in Hong Kong is violence you that is the
key you ignore the fact that China's
plan has been to chip away at Hong
Kong's freedoms and democracy until they
were all meaningless and then Beijing
could reassert full control that has
been that that's been the plan hasn't it
again with due respect I disagree why
should Beijing or the central government
in Hong Kong take away any liberties or
freedoms in Hong Kong but they do they
did mr. Dyk the kidnapping of five Hong
Kong booksellers who just happened to
turn up in mainland China the crackdown
on those who led the 2014 process a
highly controversial decision to allow
mainland Chinese police to operate in
the West Kowloon station all this is
chipping away at the freedoms of Hong
Kong Beijing imagine that people
wouldn't notice this I think we need to
really keep an eye on the big picture
that is ever since 1997 Hong Kong has
managed to keep its relative
independence judiciary independence for
example political system there's been no
change in cetera if you talk about
specific cases we can go into details if
you have more time let's deal with
universal suffrage because that's been
most controversial the refusal of the
Hong Kong government to move towards
universal suffrage for the chief
executive position as outlined in the
basic law even after the Standing
Committee of the National People's
Congress in Beijing ruled that 2017
could see the start of universal service
for this position the date came and went
so the promise hasn't happened has it
then perhaps Beijing never intended that
the promise should be fulfilled and I
think we need to be clear as to what we
are talking about universal suffrage no
problem with that you already have
universal suffrage for the District
Council election in Hong Kong as we wish
its meaning it's very important that you
don't have it for the chief executive
despite the fact that this promise
that's in the basic law then again allow
me to mention who you are talking about
universal suffrage or direct election of
the chief exec exactly yeah
does the United Kingdom have dere
election for the Prime Minister no we're
talking about what's in the basic law
for Hong Kong Macau we're not talking
about what things are like in Britain or
in America or on Mars you can play the
what about game
definitely I'm talking about Hong Kong
what it said was in in the basic law the
ultimate aim is the selection of the
chief executive by universal suffrage
upon nomination by a broadly
representative nominating committee in
accordance with democratic procedures
and that didn't happen these questions
are everywhere for everyone to see the
unis universal suffrage is not a problem
there are election that the protesters
are now demanding is a problem because
why do you want to give Hong Kong
something that neither the United States
nor the Dalek Kingdom have had for
hundreds yes is what they see that they
were promised mr. Gow right now as
you've pointed out Hong Kong residents
have freedom of the press freedom of the
internet actually dependent courts
multi-party elections even with with the
District Council's does Beijing
seriously think that by 2047 these
people I ever going to willingly give up
those no I think the one country to
system applies only up to 2047 now
remember went in shopping were still
alive and he was the key architect for
the one country to system he said for
the record that if the one country two
systems will work out for the first 50
years why couldn't it be extended for
another 50 years so there is an
uncertainty as to what will happen in
Hong Kong after 2047 I would say
everything will come to an end if for
example violence continues in Hong Kong
however if stability prosperity
development and the improvement of the
people's living standards are the normal
things all the way leading up to 2047
why couldn't the one country to system
applies you have to talk to the
Beijing's leadership but if if things
don't go to Beijing's liking and I'm
sure they're not too pleased about the
protests and the demands for freedom and
the demands for China to live up to its
promises and its international
obligations
do you think the people are going to
accept life in China crushing level of
censorship well the UN High Commission
for Human Rights recently called a
context of increasing limitation on
fundamental rights in China using people
in Hong Kong whatever except allow me to
mention one point you know putting Hong
Kong in the overall magnitude and the
scale of China whatever bad things that
have happened in Hong Kong over the past
six months
I think is is is at the best can be
called a storm in a teacup it's not
going to change meaningfully anything
that's happening in People's Republic of
China at all what page in these are
happy about and adamantly is opposed to
is the violence in Hong Kong let's be
honest and straightforward with it no
country either Britain or the United
States will tolerate the level of
violence that has engulfed Hong Kong for
the past six months no country has China
step in and stop it well let's be
philosophical about it if you read the
basic law the primary responsibility of
maintaining law and order rests with the
Hong Kong SAR government yes and they
approved government yes it's endorsed
and man they did it by the basic law my
point is though that if China fully
takes over control of Hong Kong in 2047
and think so little of human rights as
the UN says it does do you really expect
the people of Hong Kong to embrace the
kind of life you have in China I mean
the legal obligations and commitments
the multiple laws decrees and policies
in particular those concerning national
security and terrorism which the UN says
deeply erode the foundations for the
viable social economic and political
development of society you think after
having the freedoms that they have in
Hong Kong they're going to accept that
kind of life from China let's be honest
about it
China is in firm control of the
situation in Hong Kong as far as
sovereignty is concerned no one in the
world can really second this
second guess this point all really take
Hong Kong away from China that's for the
record let's do not second-guess about
that
of course under one condition system
Hong Kong keeps its political system in
Hong Kong the capitalist system but do
you think anyone will realistically
expect the Hong Kong can be misused as a
stronghold against China know either
today all the way to 20 47 the question
is which is whether you Beijing imagines
Hong Kong would ever accept the kind of
restrictions that Beijing imposes on its
own people on the mainland after 20 47
China has full discretion to decide what
kind of political system will prevail in
Hong Kong well no one full of Hong Kong
gets in return for being subsumed into
China a chance to be spied on by what
Human Rights Watch called one of the
world's most intrusive mass surveillance
systems whatever happens will happen in
Hong Kong after 2047 then - record of
arbitrary detention torture and
violations of right to a fair trial you
really think the people of Hong Kong I
say gosh I need some of that in my life
I'm really looking forward to that I
think in today's world we should be very
objective and non biased about China
let's look at how China's developing
let's look at China lifting hundreds of
millions of people out of poverty let's
look at how Hong Kong has benefited it
tremendously over the past 22 years
after being part of the one country
system after China we exercised a
sovereignty over Hong Kong so I diseases
the maggoty let's talk about censorship
mr. Gao and in an interview earlier in
the year you called it unfortunate
censorship in China you said hopefully
eventually there will be less censorship
leading towards no censorship at all and
I hope there'll be a day when people in
China can freely watch foreign
broadcasters that's pretty full on hope
isn't it when you consider that 400
million extra CCTV cameras are going
online
and the unprecedented degree of
intrusion by the state into people's
lives that we're seeing things are not
moving in the direction what you quoted
was my view earlier this year it is
still my view today and I think it will
remain my view for the rest of my life
going this way no lesser such a ship may
be good however every society has its
own sensitive issues to censor about
look at the United States they says a
lot of things that the people here in
Britain do not care about in Britain you
censor other things in Israel they just
stay with China you admitted this you
said the monitoring of social behavior
of people in China does exist there are
quite a few aspects of that which I
personally do not like yeah is the
detention of around a million wieder
Muslims in Xinjiang one of the aspects
that you don't personally like I visited
Sinjar many times are many we go friends
Islamic friends
I didn't ask you that I deal with them
as brothers and sisters I think to
really ask responsible questions about
ginger we need to know the spread of
terrorism and separatism and extremism
in change there hasn't been any
terrorism in Xinjiang for the last four
years why because you've locked up
people without rights and without
recourse and without any redress and
without the ability to challenge their
own incarceration you think that's a
good way of doing things we're talking
about the detention in so-called
training centers which were first denied
and then finally admitted by Beijing
last year the UN says people were sent
there under the guise of
counterterrorism and D extremism
policies which you've just mentioned and
amid extensive limitations on the
exercise of fundamental rights in
Xinjiang are you proud of them let me
make a point terrorism just do not come
out of the vacuum terrorism is the
result of a process and the process is
very much dominated by indoctrination
the extremism for example in Xinjiang
there is no denying there is an
increasing level of radicalization many
families actually deny their kids the
right to education which in China is
considered as an offense or a crime no
one in China has any right to deprive
their kids mr. Gajic oldest war the
Japanese expressing concerns about
increasing practices of arbitrary
detention enforced disappearance absence
of judicial oversight and restrictions
on the right to freedom of expression
freedom of thought conscience and
religion quite a list isn't it quite a
list also the right to freedom of
assembly and movement within what it
calls an increasingly securitized
environment this is a catalogue of
rights to which your government has
formally signed up in in binding
international treaties and which it is
now violating wholesale and I'm asking
you whether you're proud of all that two
points first of all the United Nations
generally speaking is in line with what
China has been doing over the past four
decades or so it's in line with the
treatment in Xinjiang as you well know
more than 50 countries in the world
support what the Chinese common is doing
in Xinjiang in dealing with terrorism
extremism if the separatist state so are
hardly beacons of human rights many of
which are Muslim in context let's let's
be honest about many of these countries
are Islamic state you proud that the
u.s. stayed at all in the world no
really you're proud that the UN had to
remind you that you have an obligation
to respect and protect individual rights
under the Universal Declaration
absolutely human rights are very very
important yeah why do you think all the
view of your international know if you
put it in international context the
United Nations keeps reminding the
United States and many other developed
countries of the rights that they fail
to give to their people that's on a
routine basis talking we're not talking
about the US I know you want to evade it
I know it's embarrassing nation you
cannot talk about this in isolation
that we can absolutely talk about what
China is doing in Xinjiang in isolations
mr. Gao one of them requests for
information submitted to Beijing last
month by 12 UN Human Rights reporters
was was this please provide detailed
information on the judicial oversight
and control exercised by judges of a
persons placed in re-education
facilities following charges under the
counterterrorism law let me make a bet
with you this request is never going to
be answered by Beijing is it let's do
this I hope with my helper with other
people's help you can do an interview in
Xinjiang I can help you to arrange some
of these you're not answering my
question
it's not because I play Jing is not
going to answer this because there's no
judicial oversight over the million or
so we Gers in detention most of the
inmates have neither been charged with
nor convicted of any crime nor being
given any chance to challenge their
incarceration as I said earlier and
that's fair and you're happy with all
that no I think you miss quote the
situation radicalization is a process at
different stages of radicalization you
need to come up with strategies to D
radicalize the population in Jinja
including for example what I emphasized
for the record denying any family's
misbehavior of depriving their kids the
right to go to school thanks to leaked
documents and despite considerable
attempts at secrecy by Beijing we now
have massive amounts of detail about
what these institutions are doing
including a leaked manual for officials
running and operating these places one
of the documents that was released
described detailed controls on each
individual the students should have a
fixed bed position a fixed queue
position a fixed classroom seat and
fixed station during skills were
strictly forbidden to be changed you
like this kind of repression you support
this kind of repression you may call it
repression or you may call it
educational or training school teaching
methods if you go to a cadet school for
example if you're trained for the UK
military you
need to exercise mr. Gao we've also seen
Beijing's instruction to officials in
these camps implement behavioral norms
and discipline requirements for getting
up roll-call washing going to the toilet
organizing and housekeeping eating
studying sleeping closing the door and
so forth you're trying to build robots
in know what you read about reminds most
of people of a training camp over
training so it reminds me Jason camps
and also go the remind people of
concentration what will serve China to
concentrate people up to let's say you
see on the number 1 million or 2 million
this is not a concentration camp
as far as based on my personal knowledge
of my dealings with the Wiggles brothers
and sisters in Xinjiang this is not what
you are describing cry from reality in
Xinjiang it not not according to the
evidence seen by the UN and democratic
governments around the world these camps
let's call them concentration camps they
violate all basic rights and freedoms
belonging to human beings under the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
which you are supposed to abide by no I
would say let synovitis war against
terrorism let the British fight your war
against spread a terrorism and let's
don't confuse terrorism extremism and
separatism with what you would call
human rights democracy even if one
accepted your pre-tests you have taken
away every right that he said you have
illegally incarcerated these people
without trial and without any chance for
them to challenge that incarceration
that is illegal but that doesn't meet
your international obligations so I
would say you are imposing your view of
rule of law on to China let China have
its own rule of law this is the own
offenses at is as itseif its we are not
talking about Britain we are not talking
about you the United States we are
talking about a sovereign government
with legal rights to deal with the
threats of terrorism and extremism we're
okay
zatia that's the key in China no one in
China wants to be a victim of terrorists
the gal you love radicalization
according to the documents you're
looking at people who Harbor vague
understandings negative attitudes or
even feelings of resistance carry out
education transformation to ensure that
results achieve that's the instruction
that Beijing gives you're looking at
people who Harbor vague understandings
that's all they've ever done wrong and
for that you put them in one of these
camps and throw away the key
so you own and you think that's okay I I
think a lot of people including the UN
and human rights organizations believes
that you have forfeited the right to be
a civilized country so you are quoting
something as if it is from the Bible no
this is not sacred things this may not
be verified already using your standard
of journalism I hope you'll be
invalidated by considerable people than
journalists I hope you will really
verify this with your journalistic
standard do you telling me it's not true
I don't think that is true because what
China is faced with is terrorism
radicalization and separatism and
extremism
that's the manners in China which is
also faced by many other countries in
the world look at the bombing here in
London look at the terrorist attack
against innocent people you really want
to have this kind of terrorist
tendencies prevailing your country or in
Europe we have a common common task to
do and united against the terrorism and
that's a challenge not faced by China
along that's a challenge faced by
mankind as a whole you're a lawyer mr.
gun yes you're even a lawyer whose
license to practice in New York
absolutely youth finding out this kind
of behavior by you government is
acceptable that's remarkable no I think
the litmus test is to put an end to
terrorism that's the key no why should I
second-guess Human Rights wholesale
that's
what you say you want congratulations
align with the reality on the ground
project no shame about these conditions
this protecting human rights
listen protecting human rights will
always be the most important thing as
promoting democracy but on the other
hand fighting terrorism and extremism is
equally important in China as well as in
UK or anywhere else in the world that's
the bottom line
we need to work together to fight
against terrorism pictograph thanks for
being on complex thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]